you know mike um
i know we we talked about this a bit on
on friday
and you you you seem to have a hard time
believing that the
new england patriots didn't want tom
brady back
man it seems so weird to say it like
that but i'm going to say it like that
they didn't want tom brady to come back
to play for the patriots you know i mean
that's just
it's mind-boggling and
that wasn't their first mistake of
saying
tom brady you're a free agent and
we're okay if you don't come back
mistake before that was not offering him
a two-year contract extension and the
mistake before that
and this is where uh you know bill
belichick i'm just shocked that he
allowed himself to get to this position
because there are exceptions there are
always exceptions
when you're dealing with exceptional
people
and that was in 2014 he mentioned the
age of tom brady he mentioned brady's
age
and his contract status as justification
for drafting
jimmy garoppolo in the second round
and from that moment 2014 as you pointed
out already today
to start that season the 14th season
tom brady was 37
and since that time he's won four super
bowls
three of them with new england one with
the tampa bay buccaneers
he's won four and he's appeared in five
since 2014. that's nuts
my point is this
you should never i don't care what to
say
what what your eyes tell you what a
birth certificate tells you
you should never walk away from players
like this when you don't have a steve
young
backing them up you should never
say to tom brady you don't have a place
here my position is mike
you stay with those guys until their
arms fall off
you stay with them stay with them two
years too long don't get
don't get rid of them a year too early
and i'm just shocked that the patriots
who usually make some really smart
decisions with personnel
couldn't see the difference between say
tom brady
and laurier malloy tom brady and
richard seymour tom brady and dion
branch tom brady and any
adam benatari any number of players
where they've gone
with their their rubric so to speak of
hey
this is how we do business this is a
patriot way
you get to be a certain age certain
contract we move on and we replace you
you not with him you can't do that
that's why but with the player i had a
tough time
you said i had a tough time believing
that they just
flat out did not want him back on any
circumstances you just articulated why
like that's why it's got to be some
mutuality to this it's like
hey because it's the age
very few very few players they were
waiting they were just waiting for them
to die
right that's what i'm saying every very
few players get
are able to retire with and play with
one team their whole career
it rarely if ever happens definitely not
in football
you know we'll see a kobe a dirk or
duncan
in the nba but rarely in football does
that happen
so it's like even brady was like
wasn't that even enough at least as time
went on to say it's never going to
happen to me
but it shouldn't have happened to him
you would think if there was going to be
an exception
not just for an exceptional person but
an exception to the rule of like
you know team moving on a year too early
versus a year too late you think it'd
have been him
because they had to see that the
limitations on offense
weren't just his regression
uh inevitable regression or so they
thought
i mean michael ladue this year led the
league in deep yards
lit league in deep yards this year
right tom brady but they didn't just
miss they missed badly
on this evaluation of of what he had
left
that's why he just kind of feels and
because he ended up in such a
so much of a better situation it's in a
better situation
and not just i mean look they were
all-time great defense at least for most
of last season
um and had won the super bowl the year
before
so not to say the patriots defense
wasn't great but
because of opt-outs but
even just with the the way the defense
evolved in tampa
there's a better defense in tampa than
the one he left in new england
there's certainly better skill position
talent and that's even without rob
gronkowski coming out
out of retirement better skill position
talent in tampa than new england
i that's why i'm just like yeah but it
worked out for you though too it's like
maybe they didn't want you back but
if you're tom brady and they do want you
back and you have the option between new
england
set aside nostalgia and sentimental you
know and
the romantic hollywood story you know
ending
you gotta ch if you said tom brady you
can either retire in new england
or you can go to tampa and throw to
these dudes tom brady
even not even knowing he would win a
super bowl should have taken tampa
if he had the choice man look
i i think i always say this
and i'm always surprised when it happens
i'll say it again
i can't think of an example off the top
of my head like
of an example coming down the road i can
think of past examples
but i'm gonna say it again it will
almost thought it would be rogers
i'll be surprised when it happens you
know what breaks up what breaks up
historic teams or historic uh
relationships duo's ego whatever it's
ego it's it's like it's what did the
beatles that's what happened to the
beatles okay
i'm telling you that's what happened to
belichick and brady
it's ego look they weren't excited
by some of the things that he was doing
they didn't they weren't excited but
he's passive-aggressive
okay tom brady's passing aggressive okay
there's a flaw
so if he's got a problem he's got a way
of saying it
but he won't come out and say it
directly so what
they should have been able to get past
that like they didn't want him to
skip otas but i look at it mike and say
man i'm 40 years old i've been in your
ota
though all right i'm a grown-ass
delicious
delicious yeah right i'm a girl
i'm a grown man i've been coming to otas
and fighting for this little mythical
parking championship
the parking space since i was 24 years
old
at 40 i can avoid otas
which are voluntary right
and still get my work done only in the
nfl
do fans get mad about employees who
decide not to do something voluntary
now you you and i have both worked with
some places
i work with the people who count every
single minute
like back in the day you punch a clock
they count every time you point they
take a long exactly they take a double
breaks
yeah they take it all day vacation they
fight
for two more vacation days but tom brady
don't want to go through a voluntary
ota and you're like oh wait a minute
what's wrong with him
so it's just ego ego has has
has put the patriots in a position where
they don't have
the greatest quarterback of all time on
their side
avoidable don't make that mistake hey
thanks for watching brother from another
on youtube make sure you hit
subscribe before you leave and be sure
to watch us
3 to 5 p.m eastern time on peacock
appreciate you